And so right now I have $2 billion
paths.
Well, what's the worst case scenario if
you do it?
Anything that damages your reputation is
irreversible cuz you only get one
reputation. You literally can't bankrupt
yourself out. [__] it.
One of the hardest decisions in
entrepreneurship is deciding which path
to follow, especially when you have two
or multiple good paths. I'm at a point
in my career where I do have a very
large decision that I need to commit to
for multiple years. And I've been
spending basically every waking hour
trying to gather more data to make the
right decision. One of my favorite
things to do when I do have big
decisions is to change my environment.
And I think it happens multiple times.
My favorite place to think is actually
on planes. I often have very few
distractions when I'm on planes. And I
quite literally get perspective. Like
I'm flying up and I'm looking down at
the earth. I feel like I always make
really good decisions when I'm in the
air. And uh it's actually something that
I like really look forward to.
You know what I've been waiting for
since I've been married? Going to
Chili's.
We've gone to Chili. I had like a
seizure. Honestly, I would go because I
don't mind. I don't care about the style
of the restaurant, but I do not like
their food.
I think they have amazing chips, great
salsa, and the fajitas are strong.
I hate that you go hard on this in front
of people because then behind the closed
doors, you're like, "Yeah, it's not that
good."
If there's any time like in the fine
establishments that I go to that we
bunch now like five times like we'll go
and she'll be like, "It sucks, right? It
sucks. Say it. Say it. It's not as good
as the finest dining in the world. Just
say it." I'll be like, "Yes, it's not as
good." She's like, "See, see." And then
that's it for the rest of my life.
You're chilly as [__] and you get like a
stomach ache from it and then you're
like,
"Who are we talking about here?"
Yeah.
Who are we talking about? I think you're
telling me your story.
So, we just landed in San Diego and we
are going to Real's event, which is a
big publicly traded brokerage for real
estate agents. Our really close friend
Shiron Sravatza is the president of the
company. He invited us out. We're
probably going to have dinner with him.
We're going to speak there tomorrow. I
will be making a presentation to help
real estate agents sell more houses, but
it will not be about real estate. It'll
uh either suck or be great for someone.
Le's like, I'm just how do I how do I
stop doing all these routines? I'm like,
I can't even start. I like tried to
smoke cigarettes to get addicted to them
and I was like, I just it was too hard.
It was just too hard to stick with it.
It's like every morning it's like what I
forgot.
[Music]
The hardest part about growth is that
the better you get, the bigger you get,
the bigger the opportunities are and the
better they are. I think the easiest
litmus test is to determine how big of a
opportunity is worth your attention. So,
right now, 10x is kind of my my litmus
test. It's like we're at 100. It's got
to be a billion or more for it to be
something that I want to dedicate time
to. And so, right now, I have what I
would consider to be two billion dollar
paths. They're very different,
relatively irreversible. One has
potentially more upside, but more risk.
The other one is more certain but has
lower upside. There's lots of things
that can make a decision irreversible.
There's if it's a certain percentage of
your net worth or capital, I don't like
making those kinds of bets. This is a
quote from Sean Servata, buddy of mine.
He said, "Never want to bet the empire
for a pot of gold. You bet what you have
and need for something you don't have
and don't need. It's never a good bet.
Anything that damages your reputation is
irreversible cuz you only get one
reputation and you literally can't
bankrupt yourself out of a bad
reputation. You can't make take
reputational risk where there's only
downside. Now, if I were to say like, I
want to support this cause, I might piss
off some people, but it'll move me
towards a different group of people. So
then in that case, that's that's a
trade-off more than it's a risk. And so
that's it's different than what I'm
talking about here. And then you just
have time, you know, time that you can't
get back. Every every like moment you
spend always has the opportunity cost of
what you could have done with that time
to get a higher return. I think the
number one presentation I have on
YouTube is about that concept is the
only base thing we have is time and we
make trades for stuff. And so the people
who are better at trading it for more
stuff get more stuff. There was this
story that Tony Robbins told that I
really like that just kind of
illustrated this image is that like rich
people make bets where they can't lose
on either way. Like so there's this guy
who knows that nickels nowaday are made
with nickel or whatever the material
they make nickel with is more valuable
than the cost of a nickel. this
billionaire knows has taken the nickel.
He's putting it in storage as an
investment because the day that they
change or remove that nickel from
currency because it makes no sense,
he'll melt it and get 40% on his money.
But there are investments that are high
return, low risk. You want to find those
bets. How's it going?
I don't want to interrupt.
You're good, man. What's up?
I I'm a treasury founder. We just find
banks in the US that literally pay the
highest rates on cash.
Well, give me your card.
I don't have a card, man. I got my
LinkedIn
here. Take a picture of me and message
me and then the guy who managed my
LinkedIn will get it. There you go. Oh,
we got to get a good lighting. There it
is.
Do it right now so I can tell them.
I'll do it right now.
Yeah. If we can get more c more return
on our cash. We're in a hot zone. A hot
zone of recognition. What's all like
entrepreneurial people? Looks like it.
Let's let this gentleman
know half measures.
That's right. He knows.
I'll tell you that story, man. We're
running gym launch making a lot of
money. I got asked to speak at this like
personal trainer conference and I was
like, "Yeah, sure. I'll I'll talk." Like
I wasn't being asked to speak. I wasn't
making content like this, so like it
wasn't like a normal. I was like, "Sure,
I'll come talk." And I was like, "So,
what do you want to do?" He's like,
"Well, I figure you just like give a lot
of value and then you can, you know,
present your thing or whatever." And I
was like, "Okay, cool." I I made this
really long presentation that was just
like very very good. And then at the
end, I had the full presentation webinar
of how to how to sell like that I used
to sell it before. And I was like, "You
guys probably don't need to see all this
stuff, right?" Like, "Okay, you get it.
Like personal training, you know, it's
important. You got to know how to sell.
Got to understand the systems." Uh, at
the end, I was like, "Yeah, and here's
the price." And I dropped it and I was
like, and I just I just went as fast as
I could through it. And then I didn't
even I said it like I'm saying it right
now. I didn't like actually say it. And
so then I revealed the price. And so I
did what would have been a 90-minute
presentation pitch in like 15 minutes
after giving 3 hours plus of value. So I
was like this should make sense. I gave
a shitload of value and then I'll just
soft toss it. Right? And I got so much
resistance from the crowd. It was the
biggest flop of a presentation I ever
gave in my entire life. I don't even
think I think I made two sales. Like it
was nothing. Right? No. I had done a
half measure. And so it's either sell or
don't sell. Don't be in between. You
either give value or you sell [__]
Don't try and mix them. If we want to
make commitments in anything or you're
trying to go all in on a decision, one
of the best ways to do that is to
eliminate the possibility of going back
on it. A lot of people spend most of
their lives being half in, half out,
which to me is just not in at all. It
just gives them an excuse to feel like
they're making progress when they really
aren't. There's a lot of books that talk
about going pro, going all in, burning
the boats. And I think they all kind of
go along the same point, which is that
sometimes you have to make a bet and be
willing to be wrong, knowing that if you
make no bet, you're guaranteed to be
wrong. But yeah, for tomorrow, everybody
there knows more about selling houses
than I do. And my proof point of that is
that they have all sold more houses than
I have. So what am I going to teach them
about selling houses, right? I think it
would be silly for me to try and compete
on that cuz there's other speakers
who've both done it and been there more
than me. So I feel like that would be a
terrible position to take. What I am
going to do is say if I were to start,
here's how I would win. But if selling
houses means winning, it'll apply.
Share with my girlfriend Riley.
How's it going?
I'm Michael.
Michael, nice to meet you. Sorry, my
hands are cold. No, you're good. I
appreciate it.
Um, dude, you're killing the game, man.
I appreciate you. Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too. Riley, right? See
you guys. When I was in high school, I
read this book called How to Make
Friends and Influence People. And I
think the second chapter or something is
Call by Their Name. It's their favorite
word in the whole language. And I was
like, "Oh, that's interesting. Your
favorite word in the entire language is
your own name. So, you love hearing that
word more than any other word." Well, I
should say that a lot of times if
somebody likes that word, think about
this from a leverage perspective. If you
haven't seen somebody in a year and then
you show up at a conference and you're
like Steve and he doesn't remember your
name, he loses all leverage, you're the
good guy. And so you have so much more
leverage in the conversation for
remembering.
Thank you for calling Reservation
Center.
Got to see if I can get in there with a
tank top and water sandals.
Thank you for calling steakhouse. Amy
speaking, how can we help you?
Amy, how are you today? Hello.
I'm doing okay. How are you?
I'm good. Quick question for you.
I have reservation at 7:30. What's the
dress code?
We don't turn anyone away unless you're
wearing the following. Board shorts,
swimsuits, and tank tops for
Well, if you've never turned anyone away
before, then I might just have to risk
it cuz I can't go back to my hotel in
time.
Oh, no. Okay.
I'm going to say Amy said it was okay.
Yeah, no problem. I'll hit that sent
over though and let them know you should
be okay. Thank you so much, Amy. You're
a lifesaver.
You're like that with the ice cream.
So, we're on our way to an ice cream
shop and it's it's closing like at the
time we're about to get there. Leila
look, she was like, "We should call to
make sure that like we can get in." And
I was like, "Hey, how's it going? My
wife needs ice cream or I'm going be in
the dog house." I was like, "What are
the chances, one in a million, that you
guys can stay open 5 minutes later so I
can get some ice cream?" I was like,
"I'll be in and out. I'll be the fastest
ice cream man you've ever seen." And
they were like, "Okay, but you just
can't tell anyone." And I was like, I
will take you to the grave except for
this content that I'm making right now.
And she let us in and we got the
Sundays. I've done a lot of phone sales
and I've done a lot of inerson sales.
And there's a lot of mini skills that
you learn in sales that are useful in
every other environment where you need
to get people to do something that you
want them to do. The ideal way of doing
is getting them to want to do the thing
that you want them to do rather than
having them feel like they are doing you
a favor. the way that you ask, the tone
that you ask, the laugh that you make,
the jokes that you make, all of those
micro things, I do those things so that
the person on the other end feels like
if they see me in person, it will be a
positive experience and they want to
have that reward and so they are willing
to push or bend the rules a little bit
so that I can do whatever it is that I'm
trying to do or get in a restaurant or
dessert or whatever it is. People do
nice things when they're in nice moods.
So, it's like get them in a good mood
first, then ask for the nice thing.
[Music]
So, you made half the presentation last
night.
Yeah. I kind of have this like process
that sort of works. I'll like outline
what I'm going to say like far in
advance and then the day before I'll
change half of it. Oh, we get the we get
the VIP entrance. Okay.
And then we noticed that your
presentation 300 plus slides.
Yeah, I finished it like 20 minutes ago.
Yeah, it looks good. All
looks good.
Yeah. Yeah. And if it doesn't, I'll
survive.
Okay. Usually I get more of my
adrenaline now and by the time I get on
stage, it's like I'm done with it kind
of thing. It's always directly
proportional to the prep. Yeah. This
will be the first time I've talked about
any of the stuff that I'm talking about
in a keynote. So,
I do like
I love this tall boy dude. This is
great. Get a little bit of sugar, a
little bit of caffeine,
a little bit of delicious,
and a little bit of uh [__] it. How many
people?
350.
I had 100 slides. He has 220.
I have 300.
Oh my god.
300 slides.
I'm looking forward to it.
Oh, thank you.
Have you ever done a real estate
audience?
No, I don't think so. I'm not I don't
talk to real estate agents. It's going
to be useless for them. They'll be like,
"What a waste of an hour."
I'm sorry.
There he is [__] talking
Alex.
[Applause]
A lot of you guys already know how to
win because you know how to lose. So
flip it. You guys know how to win better
than I could ever tell you. You measure
your success by whether you completed
the actions that would make it
unreasonable that you will not fail. And
then you succeed by default. And
everyone here has things that they've
written down from many of the talks of
things that you want to do or want to
think about or whatever. I would
encourage you to make that a list of
things that you will do. And then when
you go back to the same condition, your
same home, your same house, your same
market, your same whatever, you change
your behavior. And then that will show
that you learned and you took one step
to becoming the person that you
ultimately want to be.
This stuff is all top of mind in terms
of making actions that would make it
unreasonable that I fail with a billion
dollar decision is because that's
actually a decision I'm making right
now. I'm at a point in my career where I
have enough what I would consider
singles, doubles, triples that I have
decided to take a bigger swing. I'll
either win or I'll learn. Same as you.
So from the bottom of our heart, Alex,
you impacted our life. Thank you, man.
We appreciate you.
Thank you guys. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. All I want to do when 01
of you that's all I want to do
you can be
dude
you can be 100x you
stop it thank you Alex
you're good Chris
very nice to meet you
appreciate you Katie
appreciate you
photo with you and Katie
yeah sure still trap bro
I followed you since you had about 50
subscribers
packed here to see you I'm going to earn
that hat I bought I'll go wear it
someday thank god I was hungry I love
seeing Mosy Nation in the Wild. I love
the hustle. I love everyone coming up
and and and sharing their their their
stories. Like, that always makes my day.
I would say though, do it in a place
where you won't, you know, get put in
handcuffs for sneaking in. Come up when
you see me in public if you can. I'm
happy to say hi, take pictures,
whatever. Don't go into areas where
you're not supposed to go in order to
try and hang out because it usually just
doesn't end well.
The crowd is loving you.
Very nice to meet you. Thank you so
much. Appreciate it.
So, that was that was great. I did my
keynote earlier in the day. I think
people liked it. They may not have. I
think they sat through it regardless.
And I think we're probably going to have
the afternoon, probably a couple hours,
probably walk around and then we'll head
back to Las Vegas.
See you
content.
Yep.
[Music]
Back in the day when I had one-on- ones,
there was a one guy who I was like, "So,
like, what have you done for personal
improvement? Like, what do you you know,
have you?" He's like, "Yeah, you know,
it was so crazy. Like, I realized if I
if I don't watch Netflix as much while
I'm working, I get like so much more
done." I was like, "There's so many
things wrong with that statement." You
were telling me probably just like just
level one of idiocy. Level two of idiocy
is that like you mentioned that you were
doing that you were watching no fix in
general while you were working. Point
three is that you didn't actually say
you were going to stop. You just said
that you cut back on how much Netflix
you were watching while you were
working. And I was just like there's so
many stupidities interwoven into so few
words. I was flabbergasted. So, you're
more productive when you don't watch
Netflix movies. Not as much. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. As much as many shows in a row
while you're being paid at your job.
Yeah. It's been great.
[Music]
That's pretty.
That is pretty. Oh, damn.
So if you're at the crossroads between
one decision that you're trying to
choose between two different paths, if
it's the first goround, I would
encourage you to take the lower risk
path that has a higher chance of success
if it's a business. There are stories of
just unbelievable entrepreneurs. But
what you don't hear is the tens of
thousands of entrepreneurs who make that
massive bet and then lose everything and
lose 5, eight years of their lives. If
you are going to make the big swing and
kudos to you, it's an absolutely
personal decision. Burn the boats. Go
all in. Fully commit. Eliminate
alternatives. No half measures. Because
what I can guarantee you is that if you
are going after the big swing, the way
to guarantee that it does not work is to
go half in. So if you're going to win,
make it unreasonable that anything that
was in your control was not controlled
for and then only lose for things that
were not under your control. What do you
think? Top five. For me, I go matrix all
time. I'd be willing to put Dark Knight
as number two. It's just like he's such
a good villain. It's just like he was
just the perfect villain. The intro
scene is just like one of the all-time
best scenes ever. I really like
But I do like Gladiator Russell Crow.
You have one that's not like action
heavy.
Probably my favorite comedy. [__] No,
it's too hard. 40 Old Virgin, Wedding
Crashers, Super Bad, and Surprise. Uh,
Bridesmaids. I cried during bridesmaids.
Just like I couldn't breathe. I was
dying. Yeah. I mean, I went cuz a buddy
of mine at the job that I was at was
like, "Let's go see it." And I was like,
"Fine." And so I like had a couple
drinks and like went to the movie
theater and I like was hyperventilating
cuz I couldn't [__] stop laughing.